en cuál de las siguientes imágenes está
la vaca junto al pollito selecciona una
respuesta cuál crees que es la respuesta
bueno en esta imagen no están juntos y
en esta sí lo están así que voy a
seleccionar la opción b
hagamos otro ejemplo cuál elefante está
detrás de los ladrillos piensa en esto
cuál está detrás de los ladrillos v
bueno en la opción a el elefante está
enfrente de los ladrillos esa es la
opción b que el elefante parece que se
oculta detrás de los ladrillos como
escondiéndose muy bien seleccionar la
opción b
hagamos un ejemplo más cual figura está
debajo del rectángulo verde si revisó
esta imagen aquí encuentra nuestro
rectángulo verde y cual figura está
debajo bueno vemos este triángulo rojo
este está debajo del rectángulo verde
terminamos